hey everyone it's joanna here a lot of
you have been requesting
for a low impact workout which is gentle
on the knees today's workout is going to
be a 15 minutes workout
that is suitable for anybody who has
previous knee injuries or
if you just want a low impact workout so
we will not be doing any
deep squats or lunges and it's going to
work your entire body
so let's get started
let's start by matching on the spot each
workout will be for
40 seconds long with a 20 seconds rest
in between okay
so i just want you to warm up your body
much on the spot
drive your knee up and
just start nice and easy i want you to
listen to your body throughout the
workout
and only go as far as you can okay if
you can't
squat as low or if you can't lunge as
long or step back as slow
then just listen to your body okay now
let's just curl your leg up
nice and easy try to get your heels to
reach
your butt if this is too much then half
curl
okay again listen to your body you know
your own body
best half curl off full curl
and bring your heels to your butt
and just open up and stretch your chest
and back good now just twist and reach
the opposite side
twist and reach feel the stretch on your
lats
and the movement should also be coming
from your core twist and reach
and good okay the first workout is going
to be a
low impact jumping jacks okay so what i
want to do is
reach your arms up step out tap down and
tap down okay so step out
reach and tap so what i want to do is
keep your knees bent
throughout the entire workout do not
lock your knees because
that's not good for your knees okay so
keep your knees slightly bent
and just tap and reach as far as you can
feel the squeeze on your glutes as well
so reach up
and try to get your palms to touch each
other
good step out and reach there you go
point the toes and point
and you should feel your body warmed up
as well
reach and tap good next workout
low impact burpees so what i'm going to
do is
get down onto the floor but we will not
be including any jumping movements
so get your palms down onto the floor
step back into a plank position step
forward
and come back up if this is too much
what you can do is to reach one palm
down
one leg back the opposite arm down step
back
up and reach up okay so one
step at a time and come back up
if this is too much again remember you
can
just release one pump one pump up one
pump back
and step forward and reach up
straighten your back back down so it's a
total body workout
it's going to work all the major muscles
in your body but without any high impact
movement
reach up step back down push it back
remember do not pike your butt up as you
get
into a high plank position and come back
up okay next workout a little bit
more cardio endurance what i'm going to
do is
take a step back and just tap the
opposite knee
so we're not doing a deep lunge okay
it's just a step back
with a slight bent on your knee and just
tap
and reach okay so just
one leg at a time you should feel the
burn
on your thighs and your
glute tap and reach tap and reach
and remember to brace your core engage
your core
to balance yourself tap and reach tap
and
reach go as far back as you can if you
can't
just step forward reach okay choose your
option if not
step back and tap
try to bring your knee as high up as you
can
last few more tap and reach and
rest it out all right next
double knee with a double leg raise
so opposite end tap
and raise raise okay i don't want you to
kick and jerk your knees that is not
going to be good
for your knees so just gentle tap
reach up and reach up have control
control your legs
drive it back in drive it back in okay
tap
opposite side and raise it to the front
remember do not kick and jerk your knees
this is not going to do your knees any
good reach
reach tap tap reach
and reach good knees and
leg raise to the front up
good so the ball of your feet
should be facing forward
that's two more tap and tap
all right good next workout we'll be
working
on your outer thighs it's going to be an
outer thigh
lift so again let's focus on one side
what i want to do is just support
your left arm on your left leg and all i
need to do is
lift it up tap it down lift it up
tap it down and squeeze this part okay
so it's your outer thighs and your outer
glutes glutes
tap and down find that balance
tap and down good keep going
final balance brace your core a gentle
tap
and down good keep going
up and down and remember to just
rest your left hand on your left
leg up and down last few more
squeeze right at the top hold for one
count
control it back down last one more and
good okay standing cross crunch
stand shoulder width apart with the toes
pointer forward hands up
by your side what i'm going to do is
twist and try to get your knee as high
as you can
and reach your elbow if this is too
difficult
have movement okay if not
as high as you can and twist i want you
to
work on your core muscles twist
from your torso twist and
reach remember to keep your body upright
chest open back flat so do not hunch
forward
this is wrong it's about bringing your
knee up
not leaning your body forward
keep going and keep your hands
by the side of your head keep twisting
that's one more
and good okay one final
workout and you will get a one minute
break it's going to be
side shuffle so what i'm going to do is
start in the center
shuffle to your side and i'm going to
tap down
shuffle to your side and tap down
try to tap as slow as you can okay if
not just reach
for your calves shuffle to the side
cough
or touch the floor
tap good tap down
nice and easy find your rhythm
and tap good do you feel the work on
your legs
your glutes touch down
okay can you bring up the speed slightly
let's go tap and touch
good just lightly bounce on
your feet it's not a big movement it's
not a big
jumping motion it's just a slight bounce
and tap well done take a short
one minute break and we want to repeat
the entire circuit
once more grab some water if you need to
whap your sweat
keep yourself hydrated
[Music]
are we ready for the second round
you know your own body if you want to
add more challenge
then bring the speed up slightly okay so
the first workout is going to be a low
impact jacks remember i want you to
really feel the work on your legs
and your arms as well start right in the
center let's go
tap it out reach as far as you can and
keep your knees bent reach and tap
all right good let's bring the speed up
let's bring your heart rate up let's add
in
more intensity to the workout low impact
but it's gonna burn let's go tap it out
reach and reach remember to keep your
elbows
slightly bent as well so do not lock
your elbows
good as far as you can step out to the
side
and that's one more
and check it out low impact burpees okay
so choose your option
step let's get into a high plank
position down
push it back into a high plank and come
back
up reach back up down push it back
step wide and reach okay
let's go 40 seconds in and
reach remember to break your core keep
your body upright
stretch it out point your fingers
to the ceiling up good
and in
and i want you to try to maintain a high
plank position
and come back up so do not pike your
butt up or dip
your hips and reach
good let's not stop right now let's
maintain your heart rate
let's keep it going and up okay
step back with knee tap so we have
worked on our right leg this time
let's work on our left side so left leg
forward
right knee back okay so again remember
there should be a slight bent on your
left knee it's not a deep lunge
okay slight bend tap tap
and tap that's it as far back as you can
and tap so reach good
drive your knees in
and feel the burn on your glutes
your left legs and thighs find your
balance
find one focal point keep going
step back
good job
last two more one two
and shake it out okay double knees
with a double front leg raise okay
so remember opposite knee to the
opposite hand
reach and tap keeping your body upright
do not lean forward this is wrong okay
tap tap a gentle raise
tap and tap do not jerk
your knees tap tap add
a little bit of twist as you reach
your knee towards your palms
good twist and twist
keep going kick up
twist twist
good
we have few more seconds to go
plus one more reach reach
and just shake it out okay
outer thigh lift okay so this time we
want to work
on your left leg so
gently support your upper body on your
right leg
and all i'm going to do is lift your
thighs up
up and squeeze okay feel the squeeze
on your outer thigh and glutes up
and up find that balance squeeze it
lift it as high as you can hold it for
one count right at the top
up and back down good
don't rush through the workout i want
you to feel
the muscles working the right muscles
working
up tap down and up
and just look straight ahead good tap
down
and up
last few more up and down
okay cross crunch one of my favorite
standing ab workout it's going to work
on your torso your abs
but you don't have to be down on the
floor so this workout
is great not only for those of you with
bad knees but also
bad neck or back so arms by your side
twist remember the goal is to get your
knee
to reach your elbow while keeping
your back flat and your chest up
okay i don't want to see you collapsing
forwards
keep your body upright reach and twist
good breathe in
and out breathe in out
easier breathing hands by your head
you got this last few more legs up
let's not stop right now bring your knee
up higher
one more and good okay
the final workout is going to be a
slight shuffle
so choose your option if you can't touch
the ground then
do it if not just gently tap onto your
ankles okay
so remember that it's a light bounce
nothing
too intense ready let's go
tap it down patch down
shuffle to the side double shuffle touch
down and touch
tap good there you go last
workout
and we're going to be cooling down
together okay 50 minutes of
solid workout to kick start your day or
to end your day
go low tap
one more on each side last one
and come back up okay all right
just take this moment to bring your
heart rate back down
just breathe in breathe out
and take a deep breath in and out
all right right now let's just
do a little bit of stretching okay so
what i'm going to do is
if you have a wall balance yourself
on the wall and just grab hold of your
left thighs
and just feel the stretch on your quads
okay find your balance
do not open up or do not sway to one
side
stand in a straight position and just
stretch it out
good now release change
the other side so grab hold of your
ankle
and feel the stretch on your quads
and just breathe
all right good and now a little bit of
stretch on your hamstrings
what i want you to do is step wide with
the toes pointed out
keep your knees bent okay so always keep
your knees soft
link your arms together i want to drop
your body and just sway
from left to right you should feel the
stretch in your
from the left to the right
good i really like this stretch it's a
really good stretch
and it's a great way to cool down as
well let's go
push it back down and up
one more and up okay
all right now let's take three deep
breaths okay
breathe in link your arms link your
hands
reach reach reach and breathe out
so really feel the stretch on your back
breathe in
stretch
one more breathe in stretch it up
okay very very well done
that is the end of a 15 minute workout
which is
low impact and gentle on your knees if
you enjoyed this video
be sure to repeat this video do this
video
frequently at least three to four times
weekly and you can also combine this
workout with my other low impact
exercises
on my youtube channel be sure to give
this video a thumbs up
share this video with your friends
subscribe to my youtube channel
and i will see you in my next workout
session all the best and stay safe